I am Enrique Pena Loza
consultant and urban vision and strategy
former mayor of Bogota
to me at some point I became more and
more evident that what really makes a
city a good city is its pedestrian space
that's what really makes the difference
a city were you have great sidewalks
great parks great pedestrian streets
great glasses that's what the city
really is I mean out of the whole planet
the only microscopic space to which we
have free access especially if you are a
poor student and you have a car or even
money to go anywhere by train is
probably pedestrian space in your city
the rest of the planet
Mini's we cannot go to our countries
without having some Vsauce on permission
from our countries to let us in we even
in our country or land is private we
cannot go to this land
a good city should provide for some
human needs that we have doesn't itself
for example we need to work not just to
survive but to be happy
we could survive inside an apartment or
our life but if we can walk and then if
we can walk in 10 meter why sidewalks
it's better than to walk in 2 meter wide
sidewalks and then here again we come to
an issue which is that there are no
mathematical formulas and it comes to
designing cities is a very ideological
despite well mr. Fujiyama said that
there is no more ideological discussion
everything about a city is ideological
because it's something that cannot be
proven right or wrong the height of
buildings the how do we mix commercial
and residential shops and housing how I
should say would be how abundance should
parks be almost everything that makes a
city better or worse is not something
that can be the finest in a certain
mathematical or technical way but so we
need to work we need to be in contact
with nature so we need also to have some
trees or water or we need to be with
other people we like to be with other
people we should be able to walk to buy
milk if we have to take a car to buy
milk or to buy bread then we don't meet
many people in the street and we need
not to feel inferior and one thing a
great city does is that it puts very
wealthy people next to very low income
people together as equals in parks in
water fronts in sidewalks in public
transport
hopefully in cultural activities those
are some but again we come back here
always to the Equality
issue
many people thought after communism
failed that we could forget about
equality that this was just an obsolete
issue we should just worry about
economic development and that everything
will fall into place and then we even
have mr. Fukuyama writing this is the
end of ideology we all agree now on
everything the market is the solution to
everything but I'm not so sure because
actually we we have been trying to have
more equality for the last 2000 years I
mean even more Greece Rome the
judeo-christian revolution I would even
say that Western civilization came to
happen not because he had more advanced
technologies or mathematical knowledge
but because he had this bonding element
of equality which was finally the basis
for private property and laws that
protected citizens rights and things
like this but over the last 300 years
was all kinds of conflicts for more
equality so we cannot all of the sudden
say that equality is bunk so what kind
of equality can we talk about today not
income equality clearly because we all
agreed now that the best way to manage
muscle society's resources is private
property and the market and that creates
income inequality but what kind of
equality so I would say at least
equality of quality of life at least for
children that all children shall have
access to do everything they need to be
happy to green spaces without being
members of a Country Club to sports
facilities to libraries to water fronts
and another basic principle of equality
I would say is a pure basic principle of
democracy which is in all democracies
the first article in a constitution is
that all citizens are equal before the
law
and a consequence of that which is
explicit sometimes in the Constitution's
if not always implicit is that public
good prevails over private interest this
is an extremely powerful principle in
public of reversible private interest
for example we should not have private
land around growing cities in the
developing world we should never have
private waterfronts especially around
urban areas so there is much to do even
in the United States for example all day
long island coasts should be public a
great Greenway public park and not these
big fancy houses in front of the water
if we really have a true democracy at
work I mean if we have public good
available private interests public
transport should have priority of a
proper private cars in the use of road
space
only in 2009 or 2010 or 2008 the world
became more urban than rural for the
first time in history the developing
world cities are growing extremely fast
Latin American urban development
happened mostly between 1950 and 2000
and the same thing that happened in
Latin America going from about 30% urban
to about 70 or 80 percent urban is the
same thing that is happening in nation
now between 2000 and 2015 only in Asia
urban population is growing like by 45
million people per year but the amazing
problem is that we are not really well
organized for this this is something
that is much easier than putting
somebody on the moon but yet and they we
have slums in many many countries all
over the world we have people either in
slums or people living in overcrowded
rooms with the whole family
if we find slums everywhere it cannot be
because there was a bad mayor but
pressing because it cannot be that all
mayor's are bad or stupid or corrupt
everywhere in the world there is a
problem with the system and the system
has a problem because the market economy
does not work well in the case of land
around growing cities the market works
well when prices increase I mean when as
prices increase for example in the case
of tomatoes the price of tomatoes
increases tomato production increases
and then the prices go down but in the
case of land around green cities if the
price of land increases the supply of
land cannot increase especially not the
supply of land adjacent to the city
where there is access to water to
schools to jobs to transportation so
there is really no justification for
land around cities being private in the
countries such as Sweden or Finland
since around 1900 1904 all land around
the cities belongs to the government but
in developing countries a few rich
people own the agricultural land around
the city and they make enormous
unjustified gains in their
transformation between this land from
rural to urban and they really are not
effective tax schemes to to tax this on
earn the profit from them and the
problem is not so much that they make
unearned unjustified profits but the
products that the poor cannot solve
their housing in any good well design
neighbors in the right places so the low
income people go to the wrong places
sometimes many very often two places
will have high risks such as a landslide
risk and some very high steep hills
where they have to go to live or to as
flooding areas which floor and many
people die
or anyway these are neighbors which they
have not enough public spaces not enough
roads or enough parks not enough
anything
we are at a time in where people believe
in the market that the market solves
everything
in the case of cities the market does
not work very well
government has to intervene the market
does not work well in the case of land
around growing cities the market does
not cannot decide how wide sidewalks are
or how high buildings are how many parks
we should have with the market will
never create central parks its
government that will create these
central parks and the pedestrian
walkways and so in this case of cities
the market does not work well here is
society through something that we call
government even though it's a dirty war
to many people that has to decide what
to do the market will not create great
cities the market is creating gated
condominiums in suburban low density
developments
I don't think that is a contradiction
between economic growth and public space
first of all I think the most crucial
competitive factor in our time is is not
the crude the crucial competitive factor
in our time is not like he was in the
past land or even capital but people how
to attract and retain the best qualified
people so I would say the most crucial
competitive issue in our time is quality
of life and public pedestrian space is
crucial for quality of life public
pedestrian space gives the sea to the
quality it needs to retain great people
but also it's very important for the
people who live there themselves for the
poor I believe that there is no
contradiction whatsoever in trying to
have investments in great public
pedestrian space but great holy place
rent space however different from most
things governments do he is not just a
means most things governments do what a
means to economic development
governments invented roads in tunnels in
irrigation districts in ports in
airports because it's necessary for the
country to to produce material goods and
services Polly pedestrians pay but but
but they are a means to an end the end
what is the end the end is happiness in
the case of public pedestrian space it's
a very peculiar good because it's an end
in itself I mean it's just to have great
public space makes people happier and
creates more social integration again I
believe it also creates economic
development because actually for example
if I ask some people to go live in some
I mean some citizen ether-wall have
serious
like Lagos in Nigeria if people want to
get some person to go live in Lagos um
some expert engineer and something they
will have to pay him very very much to
compensate for the hardships of being in
Lagos if they had if instead when people
go to Paris it happens the opposite
people are willing to take a reduction
in their material will be in they go to
OPD we go without a car they go with a
much smaller apartment because the city
gives them so much back so actually to
invest in a good city is good business
it's not robots and making investment
decisions and we need to make a city
that is attractive to I mean the people
we most want to have in a city are those
who could actually go anywhere in the
world they want because they are such
good technicians or an artist or
professionals and whatever they do that
they could choose to go wherever they
want and if we don't have a great city
they will live
I love to I love to ride my bicycle I
mean I ha I have had a small apartment
in New York a very small apartment and I
would say I go around my neighborhood
buy a bicycle i go to i go through the
village I go through the East Village
I go to through Chinatown I'd like to go
across the bridges by bicycle I'd love
to take the beautiful Hudson River Park
bicycle way and go all the way up to to
Riverside Park and then to all the
opportunity to Harlem to go riding
around there to ride around the city
city college campus uptown and the I
know what is her particular place that I
like and well I like more the area that
I know more which is all the area around
the Israelis and the all this area
I enjoy there is a lot of life and a lot
of people and the Union Square area
New York was very innovative I like to
tell the people in the developing world
look New York
New York is very innovative
it was innovate in the past I like to
tell the people in the developing world
see this look European parks were mostly
the playgrounds of the wealthy of the
nobles and the Kings and the aristocrats
and sometimes it took it was necessary
to cut their heads off in order to turn
this land into parks but Central Park
was a part don't buy a democracy and it
was done around 1870 when New York was
smaller and poorer than most developing
country cities today and even with that
example developing country cities don't
have many central like Park examples to
show but I would say that recently New
York has invested again in public
pedestrian space has some done very
interesting things the Hudson River Park
the bicycle weighs what has been done
recently by Janet Shattuck candy
Transport Commissioner of mr. Bloomberg
making more bicycle ways so far only
painted lanes mostly but hopefully more
and more they will be physically
protected bicycle ways they have created
the High Line the elevated former rail
line which has been turned into a park a
bit the same as there is one in Paris -
I'm the these are fantastic public
pedestrian spaces this new public
restaurant space and some that are
taking care of by private organizations
such as Central Park but I think
first there are some things that are
still needed for the future and some
others that are have to be done to
better conserve what exist I mean the
main issue is near sidewalks I am very
concerned when your side was there is a
lot of dirt and the vendors are really
taking over the near side was and
somehow people think this is democratic
to allow anybody to go and sell anything
in these three no the vendors are not
the poor people the poor people are the
hundreds of thousands of people who walk
in new york sidewalks and if we want a
new york to be a new york public space
to be a space for integration between
the wealthy and the poor we have to keep
this clean and there is nothing wrong
about having beautiful spaces now people
just put up ATM machines in the
sidewalks and nobody seems to tell them
anything some some streets in new york
really are almost now like if they were
in the most backward developing world
cities like canal street and and but
even in many places so I think New York
sidewalks need to be better kept vendors
have to be radically restrained I mean
you may allow a few vendors supposedly
with some restrictions and some
regulations but this really and becoming
is getting to a point where it's
completely chaotic and so they say is
that there are some constitutional
restrictions to restrict vendors but I
don't see why because in Chicago
disciples are perfect and you have the
same Constitution in Chicago so I think
there is you have to be extremely
careful but the thing is that you see
that the new pedestrian spaces that have
been created or the ones that are kept
by the private sector like Central Park
or the High Line or the Hudson River
Park they are beautiful they have nice
flowers they are clean they don't have
vendors
why not manage in the same way your
public pedestrian spaces
Turkey's an example and I think clearly
is a challenge to complete the whole
bicycle way all around Manhattan in the
Upper West Side and I mean especially to
the north units necessary to work a lot
to complete the pedestrian and bicycle
walkway by the water
side there are many many streets were
protected bicycle ways are needed
because and some even seems to be I mean
some were painted initially and now they
seem to be getting rather than like in
ten straight days you know it's like
getting a race the one that was painted
so clearly clearly there is a space in
New York which is the real issue is the
parking space for cars in the streets I
mean the United States constitutions has
many rights people in the United States
have a right to live without fear with
without crime they have a right to free
education they have a right to to work
to have pride many rights but they
parking is not a constitutional right I
think it should be questioned more
seriously whether how to use this space
which is now been taken by cars parking
by the curbside it's a small minority of
people who are taking up this extremely
valuable space in the streets of New
York to park and I think in many streets
you could read get rid of parking and
make some much bigger sidewalks make
some fantastic protected bicycle ways in
all directions some regulations I think
also have to be enacted so people can
walk in with bicycles into into the
elevators and into the hallways so that
I mean if people can go with dogs or
with shoes into a into a hallway or in
an elevator why not go with a bicycle
but this New York I think Manhattan
important
is the perfect City - for everybody to
move by bicycle and even in the in the
winter it's possible in most of the
winter with some with some coats to go
by bicycle everywhere
we have had said this in the world for
about 5,000 years from Babylon and or
and all of these wonderful cities and
for 5,000 years
all these streets were only for
pedestrian even when we see pictures of
New York in 1910 you see people walking
in the street I mean in Manhattan you
see everybody my Hatton was a pedestrian
city in 1910 everybody was walking in
the middle of the street a few trams and
things and then but the 20th century was
a disaster because we made cities much
more for cars than for people and we
made horrible things such as the FDR and
things like this but happily all over
the world this began to change at the
end of 20th century we realized we had
made a big mistake everywhere that we
have made cities for cars done for
people so in Europe they began to
pedestrianised streets now there is not
one single city or town in Europe where
there is not at least several blocks or
a large area only pedestrian or a few
streets and they began to make bigger
side was to get rid of street parking
and everywhere in the world to say I
would say that in any advanced city
today
transport policy translates into how to
reduce car use
I think the best way to do it is to have
to restrict parking I mean I think more
progressively there should be a goal and
we can also as the people in New York
and me because it's only a minority of
people who have cars we should ask the
people do you want this cars parked
there or do you want this beautiful big
sidewalk with bicycle way next run in
Manhattan wait can people in Manhattan
vote on this what can people in
Manhattan vote where they want beautiful
network of bicycle ways and bigger
sidewalks or do they want cars parked
there but so I think the way to restrict
cars in Manhattan is first of all to get
rid of curbside Park in the street but
you cannot just do the negative
reinforcement to get rid of the parking
we have to give something in exchange
it's a beautiful sidewalk or a beautiful
bicycle way or both the second thing to
do is to charge for the cars coming
through the bridges which are free I
mean there are still many bridges I mean
it's very easy to do congestion charging
in Manhattan because you don't really
have to do congestion charging you just
have to charge for crossing the bridges
so it's a little even contradictory to
have congestion charging when you allow
people to cross the bridges for free so
I really believe that the first thing to
do in Manhattan is to charge in the
Manhattan Bridge and Williams abrasion
and all the bridges where people are
going across the bridge for free the
money that you collect from charging two
cars you can invest in improving
pedestrian and bicycle ways and to
subsidize public transport to make
better and cheaper public transport for
everybody
I think in many areas of New York you
will need to improve I mean New York has
some of it may be the best subway system
in the world but still it doesn't go
many places there are many places which
are underserved by public transport so
you need great public transport anything
you need to improve the bus service I
mean you need to have buses that go much
faster you need bosses that really go on
exclusive bus lanes that go much faster
to many more places to take a bus in New
York is that it's absurdly slow I mean
it's almost faster to go walking
we have to understand why people went to
the suburbs it's not because they were
dumb it's because the server's were
providing some things that the the
densities were not the server's provided
ironically safe spaces for children to
ride bicycles because because people
wanted to be tuned to play safe in the
street and ride a bicycle and ironically
this completely car-dependent
environments provided that also the
servers provide green and contact with
nature more parks but I believe is
possible to create cities which provide
a little bit of both
higher density environments you don't
need by the way 50 storey high buildings
to have high density you can have just
with five six storey high buildings you
can have very high densities huge amount
of pedestrian bicycle network greenways
bus ways and we could very easily with
very simple details have completely
different cities that would work much
better than the ones that we have today
I see all over the United States that is
Clark I talked to the Texas developers
and they talked like the most
progressive an expert urban is about
mixed use and density another but I
think we have to be even more radical
because we talked about the New Urbanism
in the US which is like going back to
this quaint 1900 town now I think we can
do some much more radical things with
much bigger pedestrian spaces some more
creative and different conceptions of a
modern city giving much more importance
to the bicycle I believe the bicycle and
now we have a new machine that are I
think it's going to contribute to
completely change the way we live which
is the electric bicycle because this
allows people to use bicycles over
longer distances or over hills or
elderly people bicycles I think we
really have to in the future I think
protected bicycle ways are going to be
as obvious as sidewalks are today to
have a protected bicycle everywhere and
the United States will have to develop
in higher density environments and the
only way to do this is demolishing some
of these inner suburbs and making higher
densities but this what I'm trying to
propose at these new developments can be
completely different not just the
typical street and cycle but you could
have as we are talking about completely
different